bonjour monsieur boccara merci et d'être
avec nous alors cette annonce de jean
castex et pour apaiser les syndicats
effectivement il cherche à déminer c'est
évident sur le fond comment dire il
ils reconnaissent qu'il ya des problèmes
kas exconnect à un problème n'ont pas
peut pas parler de retraite universel
c'est pas vrai ça c'est un mensonge de
communicants elle n'est pas universelle
ou celle qui propose en tout cas la
retraite par points ils reconnaissent
qu'un problème
ça montre que les mobilisations et les
idées qui ont été avancées payent ils
suspendent les dispositions les plus
graves mais pas toutes de la réforme
d'assurance chômage notamment celles
touchant les précaires mais aussi celles
touchant les salaires moyens et la durée
d'affiliation
mais ils disent que c'est que
transitoire donc ça pose un problème
mais troisièmement ils prennent des
décisions et castex a pris au moins deux
décisions il ya là une importante qui a
été prise avant lui
la première c'est qu'il décide de
baisser de 10 milliards les impôts des
sur les profits des entreprises
donc ça ça pose un problème parce que ça
ne fragilisera l'ensemble la deuxième
c'est qu'il décide de baisser énormément
les cotisations sociales sur l'emploi
des jeunes donc on baisse encore le coût
du travail en continu la même chose on
fragilise toute la protection sociale
tout en prétendant qu on va s'en occuper
après on est déjà en train de laminer
alors qu'il faudrait baisser le coût du
capital qu'il faudrait faire contribuer
les dividendes tout un ensemble de
choses
et troisièmement avant lui ont été
prises des mesures qui sont de suivre
tous les licenciements des entreprises
en disant on va en mettre un peu moins
mais c'est fatal il faut les accepter et
on met les des milliards de un bus ou
derrière france poursuivent les
licenciements alors qu'il faudrait au
contraire tout autre chose pour
sécuriser les gens pour les nouvelles
sécurités et pour une nouvelle
efficacité économique donc changement
parce qu'ils aident marquer le pas année
pré-électorale mobilisation des gens et
tout le monde commence à voir que c'est
tout pour le capital rien pour l'hôpital
pour dire les choses simplement
mais ce ne sont que des petits pas alors
il faut prendre moi je prends pour les
gens ont tous ceux qui souffent et pour
des millions de deux couches moyennes ou
de câbles c'est bon
mais ce n'est qu'un répit et au
contraire c'est dans la crise qu'il faut
prendre les mesures qui permet de s'en
sortir alors qu'il prend les mesures qui
vont aggraver fragiliser l'ensemble
alors selon la communication du
gouvernement si ces réformes sont
repoussées c'est pour se concentrer sur
l'avenir des jeunes 700000 actifs qui
vont arriver sur le marché du travail
qu'est ce qui est prévu pour eux et qu
est-ce qu on en faire de ces jeunes qui
arrivent sur le marché du travail
cette question de l'emploi est
fondamental c'est la mère de toutes les
batailles mais et et les jeunes sont au
coeur de la tourmente avec deux choses
l'emploi et la formation et les deux
choses sont très liés et doivent être
prévus pour l'emploi qu'est ce qu'il
fait quand même chose qu'avant on veut
dire les jeunes
eh ben c'est des sous salariés donc il
coûte moins cher on pourrait les opposer
aux autres on va baisser toutes les
cotisations sociales sur les jeunes et
on va les prendre au rabais donc les
jeunes c'est déjà on rappelé c'est une
honte mais en même temps il fragilise
toute la sécurité sociale puisque pas de
cotisations sociales pour l'emploi des
jeunes ce qu'il faudrait au contraire c
d emploi sécurisé pour les jeunes avec
une partie emploi mais un tas de
formation pris en charge par l'état
parce que tous ces jeunes qui arrivent
sur marché du travail ont besoin de
formation en même temps donc on pourra
avoir un appui qu effectivement public
dans ce sens là et une baisse du coût du
capital et pas du coup le travail c'est
à dire des dividendes ou des intérêts
bancaires
c'est sûr que pour les jeunes ya
énormément à faire la deuxième chose à
faire pour les jeunes c'est d'embaucher
énormément dans l'éducation nationale de
rehausser la rémunération des stagiaires
et des apprentis et ça il ne le fait pas
pourtant il ya 1500 milliards je dis
bien 1500 milliards c'est-à-dire près de
datta cinq fois le budget d'état qui
sont de déverser par la banque centrale
européenne sur les services publics utp
cascio et dépenses publiques et le
fameux quantitative easing 1500
milliards ça ferait 300 milliards en
france
d'autant que le budget d'état pour les
services publics pas un fifrelin pour
l'éducation nationale sans ça concerne
beaucoup les jeunes et pas un fifrelin
pour appuyer l'emploi de sécuriser déjà
monsieur vos kara merci à beaucoup
d'avoir été en direct avec nous je
rappelle que des pauvres
des économistes atterrés merci